merci monsieur le Président
13%. c'est l'écart de rémunération entre
les femmes et les hommes dans toute
l'Union européenne ce chiffre il
symbolise toutes les disparités les
carrières hachées les quotidiens
difficiles et l'Union européenne va
mettre fin à cette différence
anachronique ce résultat nous le devons
aux équipes de négociation Kira Samira
merci et félicitations et plus
particulièrement aussi à Sylvie Brunet
qui ne peut être présente aujourd'hui
son combat notre combat je veux le
porter dans l'hémicycle un combat pour
l'égalité salariale car les différences
de rémunération ne sont plus acceptables
et cet état de fait nous allons pouvoir
le changer un combat pour l'émancipation
car c'est aussi d'indépendance
financière dont il est question et cette
nécessité nous allons la garantir un
combat pour l'inclusion car au moment où
les droits des femmes régressent dans
l'Union européenne avec cette directive
nous ferons en sorte que les entreprises
prennent elles aussi toutes leurs
responsabilités pour bâtir ce combat
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
merci à vous toutes
[Applaudissements]